shall we begin still to come on Legion
I see things okay it's not real is my
brain the field narrative you make your
home again could you maybe not break
everything good I'm not gonna promise
that okay why am I so important part of
war and we're losing and you may be the
most powerful news alive we need to get
my sister back do you think Melanie's on
your side that bitch's secrets have
secrets you'll help me turn
[Music]
heating up in Memphis
we do all new Wednesdays at 10:00
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my legion episode 1 episode 2
trailer video just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to combine the episode 2 trailer video
with my episode 1 Easter Egg video most
of you said you are pretty jazzed up
about the series the stylized
look the fact that it seems so big it's
great to see an x-men TV show doing
really well everybody seems to love it
so far so I'll explain how it's
connected to the x-men movies what
they're talking about for season 2
already they're already talking about
season 2 so I'm just going to tie these
videos to the Logan giveaway it's for
IMAX gift certificates for the Logan
movie all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video about Legion so be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts I'll be doing
weekly videos just depending on how much
you guys want to keep talking about this
we'll just see how it goes it seems like
it's going to be really awesome so talk
about top 10 WTF and comic book Easter
eggs then I'll talk about the trailer
for episode 2 so number 10 his origin
story his sister the suburban upbringing
they had this great short film at the
beginning of the episode that sort of
tells you how he grew up starting to go
crazy his mutant powers started to
activate and he thought that he was
going insane the whole idea of the
series is is it what if you're not in
faith what if you're not supposed to be
normal what if these powers make you
better than everyone else that was the
Sidney Barrett quote when they first
meet each other like hey maybe this is
all bullcrap so in the comics he is the
son of Professor X and Gabriel Haller
he goes to visit this Israeli Hospital
where she's a mental patient she's
trapped inside her own mind
he's as his psychic abilities to bring
her out they fall in love they have a
child in that child becomes the David
Haller character so he's part of the
x-men canon he's appeared in some of the
larger crossovers but he's kind of like
this weird character so you don't see
him interact with a lot of the other
x-men and a lot of the big main titles
because he's so powerful so it's kind of
hard to tell stories with them because
he's an omega-level mutant with almost
1000 different personalities each of
which has its own different mutant
ability so he displayed telekinetic
powers during the episode but that's
just one of his personalities but
because the comics are so
crazy with the number of different
powers that he has I have a feeling that
they toned it down a little bit for the
TV show so that is a little easier to
follow so he has a bunch of abilities
and it's a lot like when they went to
recruit Jean Grey in the x-men movies so
they go to see her and she's so crazy
powerful that Professor X and Magneto
are just a little afraid
professor X has to slowly talk her down
so that she doesn't just completely nuke
everybody in the area but number nine
the x-men movie connections so the way
they explained this series is that it's
sort of like a season one test for them
to be able to connect to the movies so
it's all about David this season there
are eight episodes so it's the story of
him discovering his abilities and
learning that he's a mutant what that
means learning about mutant kind in the
world because in the world of the show
mutants exist people are trying to co-op
them the government are coming for them
like the government group in this
episode then you have people like the
Mutant Liberation Front Magneto's group
that are trying to rescue them so right
now just dating the series it's sort of
like post first class but you look from
the stylized costumes and the way
everything looks it's kind of somewhere
between the 60s and the 70s so that they
can give it that Stanley Kubrick
Clockwork Orange look just because it's
all about mental patients going crazy so
when we say this connects to the movies
you're talking about characters that are
mentioned things that they use plot
points big things that happened in the
Canon of the x-men films but what
they'll probably do is work up to a
Professor X reveal where as they say
David this is who your father is now
Patrick Stewart probably isn't going to
get star on the series but they might
have a picture of him they might have
pictures of the classic x-men eventually
in season 2 so they're working up to
that but number 8 the devil with the
yellow eyes everybody was asking
questions about this during the episode
it was a little homunculus that he kept
seeing in his visions he gets
hallucinating this crazy Hellraiser
looking demon with yellow eyes the
lights would go red and it would seem
like someone really evil was coming for
him there are two options for who he is
but I think it's more of a comic book
thing but because this is such a
psychological drama we have to
acknowledge the a possibility the
this is just an aspect of his dark
personality that's emerging one of his
crazy or evil personalities from the
comics the other more likely option is
that the devil with yellow eyes is
actually the Shadow King look he even
has yellow eyes in his comic book form
this kind of looks like the thing that
we were looking at he is sort of like
this psychic manifestation of dark
energy that takes over his mind and
controls his body uses his powers and
turns David super evil so there are evil
personas in David's head but the Shadow
King himself is a separate entity and
this might be who that is so what
happens is is that he lives in the body
of different people's if you remember
early in the episode when they were
interrogating him in that empty doubt
pool there was the dog in the cage you
heard the growling sound there was the
red light so every time there's the red
light the shadow King appears so that
might be the Shadow King hiding inside
that body with these government people
but for the most part they're putting
him forward is the main antagonist of
the series but the other option is as
the David becomes evil and he becomes
the main antagonist of the series after
he's possessed by the Shadow King so
we'll see how that plays out over the
course of season one but number seven
the Sidney Barrett character and her
powers so she has body-swapping
abilities she's a very roguelike
character she can't be touched like if
rogue touches you
she'll SAP your life force she'll steal
your powers so she's the love interest
of the series and she was telling the
truth at the end of the episode when she
said yes this is real but I do not think
that she was a plant in the psychiatric
facility early in the episode I think
they actually threw her in there but
there are a couple times in the episode
where you're left to wonder how much of
his time in that facility is real
because he keeps jumping back and forth
into his memories when he's being
interrogated by the government so
there's a point in the episode where
Sidney in the Brotherhood of mutants or
the Mutant Liberation Front whatever you
want to call the good mutant are trying
to rescue him and he's still back in the
psychiatric facility so you have to
assume that most of the events of the
early part of the episode up to the
incident with Sidney body-swapping
and killing all those
people that's all real and then after
that every time you go back to that
facility it's just him remembering
things in present-day hallucinating
things and for the most part she's a
good character I do like the actress and
I like the idiosyncrasies that she has
like they're lying in bed together no
don't touch me
it's just one of those really weird
things that you would see on a cable
show where they allow characters to be
super weird and super interesting I
think it's a lot of fun this show would
not exist if it were on network
television so number six Lenny's
character when she's alive and when
she's dead so here's the important thing
about this Aubrey Plaza did a great job
she's totally crazy but in present day
she's dead and she's just a
manifestation of David's head like she
says I'm dead they're coming for you so
she becomes David's subconscious warning
him about the government that's coming
to take him and study him pick him apart
but when she's alive
she actually orchestrates the events of
that first incident so you do wonder how
much she knows about David so it seems
like what's going on is that she was
actually there to keep an eye on David
for the good group just make sure that
nothing happened to him and make sure
that he unlocked his powers because that
whole sequence were they you know they
do the big incidents where all those
people end up dying is that Sidney's
walking out Dave is nowhere to be found
so Lenny steps in front of her and just
starts stalling for time till David can
run up and kiss her now that seems like
clear evidence of a plan like Lenny
wanted this to happen so that things
would go crazy and David could
eventually break out so either she's
working with the good group or she's
working with another group like The
Shadow King or something like that but
you guys can let me know who you think
that she was working with but now she's
dead she's inside David's mind so we'll
continue to see her character but she'll
just be a manifestation of his
subconscious just saying things that he
doesn't say out loud number five the
first telekinetic incident so this is
after college he stopped taking his meds
so like most mutants he has an outburst
and his powers manifest he sees it he's
like oh this is really cool but he
thinks that he's going crazy
because in this world mutants aren't a
really big thing they've existed for a
while but it's a relatively new idea so
he doesn't know how to handle it
tries to kill himself and that's how he
winds up in the facility that he's in at
the beginning of the episode talking to
his sister and actually I should say the
sister does not exist in the comics
David Haller is the only child of
Professor X in Gabrielle Haller but
number four is the second incident with
Sydney the way they explain it is is it
Sydney when she body swapped into
David's body has control of his powers
and kills a bunch of people
the reason they set it up this way isn't
to make Sydney seem like a killer it's
to let you know what happens it's the
shadow king the devil with the yellow
eyes is able to take over David's body
he'll be able to do this to everyone
trapped them behind these balls without
any doors all kinds of crazy powers that
we haven't seen yet so it's just a
cautionary tale that David himself is a
weapon of mass destruction it needs to
learn how to control his abilities and
prevent other people from taking
advantage of him in the really obvious
way like The Shadow King like literally
taking over his mind or the government
co-opting his abilities because the way
they explained these different factions
you know number three the government
group the interrogator the eye that's
actually the name of his character he's
called the eye he sort of like the
security man they have a number of bad
mutants working for them Weapon X style
so it's sort of like the Weapon X
program a bunch of evil people trying to
use these mutant abilities for their own
purposes so some of these people are not
caught up with characters their original
from the show the shadow king himself is
from the comics so there are a number of
bad people that are straight out of the
comics but they're sort of one of the
three factions you have the good mutants
which we'll just call like the
Brotherhood of mutants or the Mutant
Liberation Front to the government in
three the forces of the shadow king who
right now we only know is operating by
himself but it seems like he's co-opting
the government group like he's secretly
just following them around looking for
really powerful mutants to take over and
you find David the most powerful mutants
they've ever seen and they want to study
him so naturally in comes the Shadow
King so number two Sidney's Mutant
Liberation group you have autonomy carry
Loudermilk in melanie bird those aren't
characters from the comics but you can
see some of the
powers like they have the ability to
create explosions fire there are other
people with telekinetic powers that help
them escape here like you see them
throwing these giant rocks around during
that big action set piece so I know it
seems very Hellfire Club
Melanie Byrd seems a lot like Emma Frost
just because she's dressed in pure white
post first class they're just trying to
evoke a lot of that imagery so we might
see some Hellfire Club stuff happening
because they're not being used by any of
the other movies right now but they did
kind of make it seem like she is
actually David's mother this is the
young version of David's mother they
just call her David's mother they don't
call her Gabrielle holler but that's her
name in the comics number one is the
trailer for the next episode you just
see the montage of them sort of testing
his abilities them learning a little bit
more about him he needs to learn to
control them so that he can defend
himself against the government people
that would want to use them and against
the really dangerous people like the
shadow king so the shadow king is like
the big boss you have to imagine that
he's going to keep popping up in David's
subconscious in the back of his mind
because he's a psychic villain he's not
so much a physical villain like the
government group is but next week's
episode is going to be a big montage of
them testing his abilities learning
about what's going on inside his head
it's going to be fascinating remember in
the comics he has almost a thousand
different personalities so it'll be
interesting to see how they dilute that
for the TV show and explain all that
craziness but let me know what would you
guys favorite moment from the episode
what do you think about it I totally
love the stylized look and that's why
they chose to set it during this time
period so they could make it stand out
visually a lot more than the other
superhero TV shows that you see on right
now so tying his arc together over the
course of season one I'll leave with
this breaking bad style idea David is
not in danger David himself is the
danger because of what would happen if
the shadow king is able to take over his
mind so he's not evil himself but he can
be used for great evil great mayhem so
episode to posting next Thursday morning
what's going to happen later tonight is
I'll post my arrow video I have some new
spider-man Home Coming Iron Man that
I'll post that will probably be Friday
morning I've been posting like three
videos a day for the last couple of days
so I'm getting ready to die from it
so I'm going to try to get it back down
to two videos a day there's just like so
much stuff that's dropping so much
footage so I'll try to stay on top of
all of it but if you have any bonus
video requests for Legion just leave
them in the comments below while you
wait for that you can click here for a
new Iron Fist footage and you can click
here to watch a new Logan trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video